sabemos que es 5 por 3 es igual a 15
entonces cuáles de los siguientes
enunciados son ciertos y nos dicen elige
dos respuestas así que pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la respuesta por tu
cuenta vamos analizando los incisos uno
a uno
primero dice 3 es múltiplo de 15 ahora
que 13 múltiplos de 15 significa que
nosotros podemos multiplicar a 15 por
algún número entero para obtener 3 pero
los múltiplos de 15 son 15 30 y 45 y
ellos nunca te darán 3 porque el número
entero tengo que multiplicar 15 para
obtener 3 bueno se multiplicó a 15 por 1
ya estoy en 15 por lo tanto por ninguno
y entonces este no será nuestro inciso
correcto y como dice que elijamos dos
respuestas correctas entonces bueno
quiero creer que seremos capaces de
encontrar esas dos respuestas en estos
dos incisos pero vamos a pensar en ellos
para ver que sean los correctos
el siguiente inciso dice 15 es múltiplo
de 3 eso significa que podemos
multiplicar 3 por un cierto número
entero para obtener 15 y en efecto
sabemos que el número entero es
5 nos lo dicen acá arriba 5 por 3 es 15
por lo tanto 15 es múltiplo de 3 por
cierto 15 también es múltiplo de 5 ya
que si multiplicamos a 5 por el número
entero 3 obtenemos 15 por lo tanto esta
es una respuesta correcta bien el
siguiente inciso dice 5 es factor de 15
ok los factores son los números que
cuando tú lo multiplicas obtienes 15 por
lo tanto 5 es factor de 15 y 3 también
es factor de 15 ya que 5 por 3 es 15 así
que este inciso también es correcto
también lo sería si dijera 3 el factor
de 15 o si dijera 15 es múltiplo de 5
cualquiera de estos enunciados serían
correctos con base en lo que ya sabemos
5 x 3 es 15